good morning John its January 20th Henry
Green's birthday can we cue the epic
music in 1995 John Green was a senior in
high school he was so cool the he took
little notice of a young freshman named
Sarah
in fact asked about it years later John
Green says well I think I thought she
was kind of cute Sarah on the other hand
quite clearly remembers the charmingly
nerdy upperclassmen though their
interactions were few after graduation
10 years and a pass before their paths
would cross again in a peculiar turn of
events Sarah was punching John Green's
ex-girlfriend in the face one day when
it came out that she was in fact from
Alabama the two were sparring partners
at a Chicago boxing club and John's
ex-girlfriend said my ex-boyfriend is
also from Alabama though she probably
didn't say it quite like that
slowly it came out that the ex-boyfriend
of the sparring partner was in fact that
charmingly nerdy upperclassman John
Green thus reconnected by the sparring
partner and ex girlfriend John and Sarah
began a string of emails that stretched
over a year and time and became roughly
the length of a short Russian novel
these collected emails have since been
the subject of intense study from
scholars in the field of
technology-based literature to scholars
in the field of true love and they led
eventually to a string of dates in 2004
in 2005 Sarah arrived home to find a
single red rose placed on every step
rising to her fourth floor apartment and
at the top waiting for her was John
Green carrying more roses and a ring
look couple were married in a beautiful
traditional ceremony two large Alabama
church Valen lived together happily for
years with their puppy fireball Wilson
Willie Roberts
it wasn't until early 2010 earlier today
in fact that John in Sara's to be game
three when Henry Green was born we can
only assume that Henry was named after
John's younger smarter better-looking
brother or possibly after his
grandfather though it is clear from the
massive black hair on his head that he
will take after his mother for which we
are all intensely grateful Henry green
was born early in the morning of January
20th the event was described by John as
freaking weird man and then later as she
just worked so hard and now there's like
this person like a person John described
the feeling of fatherhood as actually
like really great and continued to point
out that I don't even really know what's
going on man I've been awake for 46 in
the last 48 hours John Sarah and Henry
are now enjoying some much deserved rest
and we would like to remind everyone
that John's baby needs gifts so please
follow the link in the sidebar to give
John Green's baby the only gift
once a world without malaria john
green's paternity leaves thus begun
maureen johnson i will see you on friday